13 GMT and we begin this NewsHour in
Greece where coast guards have recovered
the bodies of at least 78 people who
drowned off the southern coasts after
their fishing boat sank operations are
underway to find hundreds of others who
are missing and feared dead survivors
say the boat was carrying up to 700
migrants from several countries
including Pakistan Egypt and Syria three
people suspected of human trafficking
are under investigation caretaker prime
minister Johannes sarmasa has declared
three days of national Mourning
live to Al jazeera's John ceropolis was
in Kalamata Greece where survivors are
being brought John what's happened since
we spoke the last time just about two
hours ago have any more survivors all
bodies been found
I'm afraid not there are no bodies no
survivors the search operation is
ongoing we know there's still a frigate
and helicopters and uh a high seas
Coastal uh Coast Guard vessel out there
looking also several Merchant ships but
we have had no information of anyone new
being brought every time I speak to the
Coast Guard in Athens there are no new
numbers it's very much the numbers we
had on Wednesday so the only new thing
that we've seen here is relatives of
people who are on the boat trickling in
I spoke to One Man From Italy who's come
here looking for a relative a cousin of
his I spoke to one man from Syria who's
living in Hamburg Germany he has come
here looking for his wife he had paid
five thousand dollars to have her
shipped across from Libya because as he
said it was very very difficult to bring
her over legally and he has afraid that
he's lost her forever he's showing
people pictures of his wife on his phone
in hopes that somebody may have seen her
or that somebody May disseminate that
photograph to people who have seen her
as far as we know all the survivors are
men inside this Warehouse certainly
glimpses of them that we caught from the
doorway suggest that so it's highly
unlikely that uh
women are going to be are going to be
now found sad sad stories John the
people who've been rescued as you say
mostly men from what we understand what
have you heard about their condition and
what's going to happen to them what sort
of help assistance are they receiving
from Greek authorities
we know that they were in a State of
Shock when they were brought on shore on
Wednesday we know some fainted here on
the dock we know that 32 of them have
been hospitalized five have been
released
dehydration panic attacks malnutrition
sunburn
partial drowning many had water in their
lungs all of these symptoms are being
treated the authorities here say that
they're all going to be okay
but psychologically it's a different
story it's likely that all of them have
relatives or friends who are among those
who didn't make it off the ship and it's
unclear how they're going to survive the
ordeal of of Coming to Terms right uh of
of the fact with the fact that they they
have lost these loved ones forever and
that they're going to have to carry on
whether under Asylum conditions in
Europe or elsewhere alone it's uh it's a
devastating loss because the scale of
the loss is such that there may be 600
or more people at the bottom of the sea
at the moment oh my it's just
unbelievable and really shocking
especially when you look at the pictures
of the overcrowded boat you can see the
top deck of the boat there with what
looks like at least 100 people if not
more so one can only imagine how many
could have been Lower Deck do we know
John
the circumstances of the accident
because I understand that this boat was
initially headed towards Italy in fact
how did it capsize
all we know about the circumstances is
from the Greek Coast Guard Captain who
watched it happen in the very small
hours of Wednesday he says that the boat
tilted side to side very violently until
it capsized it seems that after its
engines stopped working
there was a 20-minute period of panic
and in that time it may be that many
people were moving
across the deck or trying to find ways
to fix the engine or simply didn't know
what to do because many of these people
are from Central Asian republics
landlocked republics as we've been told
unfamiliar with the sea never traveled
over a large body of water it's easy for
a crowd like that to panic on such a
tightly packed vessel with very very few
people there to reassure them that
things can be fixed that the Coast Guard
can help them get to some Shore whether
Greece is or Italy's the Greek Coast
Guard says that up until that point
all the communications with the boat
resulted in the boats refusing any kind
of help other than food and water the
Greek Coast Guard repeatedly says it
asked them whether they needed to
offload people whether they needed any
kind of assistance and they said no we
just want to get to Italy but all of
that changed after the engine stopped
working and within 25 minutes the boat
had sunk through this tilting of weight
and capsizing
tragedy indeed thank you so much John
for bringing us the latest there from
Kalamata in Greece John serapolis